[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
George Campbell Ramsey personality host
of the extremely popular new George
camel YouTube show and also the podcast
called well at least he's a co-host of
it called a smart money happy hour and
you can check both of them out he and
Rachel Cruz do that one together the
phone number here is we talk to you
about your life and your money is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Josh starts off this hour in Idaho Falls
Idaho hi Josh how are you
doing great how you doing Dave better
than I deserve what's up
so a question for you my wife and I have
a household income of just over a
hundred thousand and we're completely
through baby steps one through three and
I'm wondering how with the current house
market we don't have a home or saving up
for a home how do baby steps four and
five change for us
why would they change
well we are just saving up for a home
and working towards that down payment
we're almost ready for the down payment
okay have you ever heard us talk about
the thing we call baby step 3B
I have heard a little bit yes okay
that's what you're talking about I think
okay so you finish your emergency fund
at three that is the point at which you
would begin to save for your home and
some people Push pause and don't do four
and don't start saving for retirement
until they build their fully until they
get their house down payment some people
save for a house while they're putting
something in retirement up to 15 for
baby step four so you can do either one
or both somewhere in there so how long
is this going to take to save up your
down payment
uh
there were I think in mid next year
we're going to have a little bit larger
down payment than is required and we're
doing eight percent of our household
income into roths right now okay and so
while doing eight percent you'll still
have that down payment by mid next year
yeah we're putting away eight percent
into the roths and about 40 of savings
just goes away into CDs until we're
ready for our down payment that's
fabulous Josh well done yeah that's what
we would call baby step 3B so 3B is all
of your savings goes into
um
into your house down payment fund up or
down to a little bit less a little bit
less a little bit less than all because
you're putting some or up to 15 in the
retirement so you're putting eight into
retirement and you're still going to
meet your down payment goals doesn't
change a thing it's exactly what I would
do have at it
okay and then would you hold off at all
until interest rates come down and just
when we get that downtown ready no buy a
house when you're ready
okay because here's the thing if
interest rates come down after you buy
the house refinance
house prices aren't coming down
we've not seen substantial drops in
house prices ever in the real estate
market except during the 2008 debacle
and we're not going to see them now
we've told you this for two years
because we've still got a shortage of
housing
there's not enough inventory too many
buyers chasing too few items causes
price to maintain stability or go up so
house price is going to be going up and
I wouldn't sit around and watch the
house prices go up while I'm waiting on
interest rates to go down bad plan
I don't time the stock market or the
real estate market
exactly both involve some risk and he's
the only time I would time the real
estate market is if I can't find a deal
when I'm buying investment property and
then wait because the Market's like
white hot and there is no deals I'm just
don't buy unless I get a good good deal
period I do not buy investment property
unless I steal it period I want to get a
great Buy on investment property your
money's made at the Buy on that but as
far as your personal residence goes buy
when you're ready which is when you're
debt free have your emergency fund
inflation have saved your down payment
yeah and I get interest rates have got
people freaked out because you know it's
hundreds of dollars more in your payment
they're going well I need to wait the
problem like you're saying Dave is those
same people are going to call us and say
Dave I weighed it and now the home price
is a hundred thousand more than it was
well and there's no guaranteed interest
rates come down
what if you sat around and waited and
they went to ten yeah they just raised
the rates again so we just don't know
1978 September I got my real estate
license I was 18. that was the year
interest rates went from nine and three
quarters to ten percent for the very
first time ever
and if it did it then and then it went
on up to 18 before it came back down and
it took it a decade to do that reversal
to go on up and then back down uh if it
did it then why can't it do it now I
mean I don't know these could these
bozos continue to screw with this
they're going to mess it up
I mean so I wouldn't be sitting around
waiting on
the outside environment to get you ready
you get ready strike while the Iron's
hot Jocelyn is and get a good real
estate agent to help you make good clear
decisions Jocelyn is with us in Miami
hey Jocelyn how are you
hey so good so nice to be able to talk
to you guys you too what's up
so I have a family quinceanera trip
coming up next June a family what
okay
my Spanish is limited to my hillbilly so
okay I got you sweet 16. yes think about
sweet 16. um it's on a cruise and
um I'm currently on babysit
es in
I've been working on you know paying it
down as quickly as possible but
um this trip is coming up and everyone's
kind of reserving it and I don't know
who is who's turning 16.
my niece my first niece oh and you're
supposed to go on a cruise because she's
turning 16.
it's a tradition yeah I guess
it's a great tradition I love it
for rich people honestly that's stuff
rich people ought to do right there
yeah not broke people
it wasn't a tradition in my house
growing up we didn't have that kind of
money I never saw the ocean until I was
15.
yeah
so how much is this cruise going to cost
um it's gonna be around
it would be around probably 8 000. oh my
goodness
where are y'all going around the world
and back
what I didn't I didn't choose this
Cruise okay I'm just trying to you know
see how to go best
what's the best way to go about it
because I understand it's expensive and
I understand I'm trying to pay off but
you're not going to be out of debt by
then
exactly what do you make a year
90 000. okay how much debt have you got
huh
60. and how old are you
30. well you're you're a big girl you
get to make your own decisions you don't
have to do what Dave and George say
you can do whatever you want to do right
I can tell you what Dave and Sharon
Ramsey would have done if we were in
your situation
we would have wished our niece
good luck and have a great time we're
not going to be able to join you because
we're broke people
that's what we would have told them
but you're not going to do that you're
not going to do that I can tell by
talking to you already you're going on
the cruise
you you there's no way you could tell
these people no
you don't have it within your being
you can't you can't just smile and say
no
nope eight thousand dollars for a 16
year old
Lord Jesus buy her a car and we don't
have the money it's going to compound
the debt problem you're gonna have to
put it on a credit card I could have
bought her a really nice car I mean and
she's gonna go in debt for her student
loans for her for when she goes to
school when she turns 18 right I'm gonna
just I'm gonna have a small calf here
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
faction guarantee and shipping is always
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
Ramsay personality is my co-host open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money so the
feds raised the rate again another
quarter of a point
um how many times have they done this
now well they're just not smart
you know because the economy is just
booming so we should definitely do
things to screw it up and slow it down
we can't have that and of course they
want to get all the pain out of the way
before there's a presidential election
so they're getting all this crap out
because people will forget to be mad two
years from now Now's the Time this is
the tenth time it says that they've
raised the rates and all in a process to
slow down inflation that was not caused
by an overheated economy it was caused
by an underheated supply chain caused by
fauci so um so attack the wrong problem
you get the wrong solution yeah you just
should have fired him long before you he
finally got around to quitting and then
you've been better off when you have
math done by the medical community
apparently they're not good at it so
this is how what we get into so anyway
yeah yeah let me try to explain what I'm
rambling about mumbling about here so
the problems with inflation were caused
by supply chain disruption supply chain
disruption is defined as a shortage of
goods the shortage of goods anytime
there's a shortage of anything it causes
the prices to go up remember toilet
paper and so uh there's a rush on it and
prices go up and people price gouge and
everything else there's a shortage on
oil because you turn the pipeline off
because you have an electric thing going
or whatever it is you got going a green
thing you got going you turn the
pipeline off and you shut down the
supply of gasoline gasoline prices go up
so the bumper the little sticker on
there says I did that with Biden yes he
did he did not do the other parts of
inflation but they were caused by simply
fouchy because when you shut down all
the factories and they don't produce
stuff you create a shortage of stuff
and the shortage of stuff causes the
prices to go up oh by the way when you
declare an entire segment of the economy
as non-essential
you're not essential talk about freaking
insulting how would you just like to be
called non-essential how do you recover
from that psychologically you're
non-essential I'm essential but you're
not essential
that's the ultimate in snobbery but
anyway we did do that right yes and uh
so if you're not essential then you
create and then when you want everybody
to come back to work well they go screw
you I'm not essential I'm not coming
back to work but by the way you're
giving me lots of money to stay at home
so I'm not going to come back to work
screw you I'm not going to wait your
tables I'm not going to make your beds
at the hotel and I'm not going to stock
your shelves at Target oh well what if
we paid you 20 an hour instead of ten
dollars an hour oh then I would come
back okay then you came back at Double
the rate almost what you were paid
pre-covered oh by the way that cost of
that loaf of bread has in it the labor
to put the loaf of bread on the Shelf
which is now double because of the
shortage created by quarantine so even
labor was supply chain disrupted all of
that created this artificial inflation
that would have smoothed out on its own
if the freaking fed had stayed out of it
but instead they decide they're going to
slow the economy down because it's white
hot which it's not
it was just going through a burp rat
through a snake trying to get itself
straightened out after the quarantine
created by felchi so now we have a
Federal Reserve that is uh trying to
screw in a Phillips head screwdriver
with a hammer
and they keep writing the wrong tool
so they're they're trying to ratchet
this interest rate up to calm people
down but people don't seem to be
stopping their spending either we're at
record high Consumer Debt across the
board well they slowed the real estate
market down what's true uh didn't help a
ton it seems no it's still do we still
have a shortage of housing compared to
the supply of buyers but um anyway so
bottom line is
uh the FED is stupid and they're trying
they're trying to get some 1970s and
1980s monetary policy to slow down a
different type of inflation that was not
created by the interest rate environment
and they're trying to use the interest
rate environment so they're literally
using the wrong tool on the economy they
really are using a hammer on a screw and
it's not it doesn't work so this is what
you're dealing with but hey The Islander
misfit toys continues their parade in
Washington so you can just count on it
so we're going to see rates go up on all
types of debt this is or the Fed rate to
be clear is nothing to do directly to
the mortgage rate okay mortgage rates
created by the bond market
so whatever the bond market does is what
the mortgage rates are going to do the
Fed rate is what banks borrow from other
banks for and so other Banks One bank is
now borrowing from another bank if it
needs some money at a quarter percent
higher so their cost of money is higher
so anything that bank does is going to
be up charged they pass it down to the
consent so they're going to jack up your
your auto rates out of borrowing rates
credit card rates uh personal loan rates
student loans home equity loan rates
anything that that a bank product that's
going into the market now mortgages are
not a bank product mortgages are a bond
market product so they're not directly
tied uh but mortgage rates the the bond
market has kind of followed along with
this particular set of increases so
that's why we have higher mortgage rates
while we've had fed increases so not to
panic but just more General discussed
with the incompetency of what the
economic and competency of what these
people call themselves as leaders and it
doesn't matter if you're Republican or
Grant stupid is just stupid there is
silver lining Dave though interest rates
for savings accounts also will get a
bump which is good for those saving up
for their down payments or their
emergency funds yeah so let me ask you
this okay not life-changing 1980 I'm in
college
rates are
mortgage rates were 17 percent
1980 1981 17 percent
um
and my grandpa and his uh at that time
in his 70s
uh was loving it
because he had CDs and money market
accounts down at the old savings and
loan that were paying 11 percent
wow in a savings account CD rates 11
percent
he was loving it he thought it was just
fancy because he didn't have any debt
and he wasn't going to go get a mortgage
and he was just cashing in on these high
interest savings accounts so it but my
my question George is is the trade-off
worth it I mean would you do you really
want 11 savings rates
and the trade-off is you got an 18
mortgage rate
no don't want that not good not good not
healthy for anybody
um sorry that your savings account sucks
at one percent back when we had three
percent mortgage rates but three percent
four percent five percent mortgage rates
because it hurts the economy more than
it helps your bank it's just stupid on
steroids the banks are cleaning up
they're cleaning up when this happens
either way they're making their money
you can count on the banks making their
money and you can count on the
politicians drawing their paycheck
or if we had those people paid based on
their effectiveness they'd all be at the
in the breadline but um but then who's
gonna pass that because they're not
going to do that well they can't even
pass term limits to send themselves home
Sunny is with us Sonny's in St Louis
Sunny give us some sunny news
okay it's always sunny around that day I
hear you brother
yeah but what I'm calling about is uh
me and my wife when we got married she
had a bunch of savings I had a little
bit of debt and then she had about
probably like 72 000 in savings
and we bought some property from her
parents that we intend to build on and
she put uh 25 or 20 down on it and now
she has more in savings we still have
some debt but I feel like it's unfair
for me to ask her to pay on our debt
with that money if a lot of the debt is
mine that I brought into our marriage
not that
not that we're not together on it but
you're married right
yeah yeah so if she gets cancer is it
unfair for you to take care of her
if she gets cancer is it unfair for you
to take care of her
no of course not well you didn't cause
it
not your fault
I'm trying to use your own logic back on
you
yeah I got you no I I yeah
and in health
for richer
for poor and the old book of common
prayer continues The Vow and it says
unto thee all my worldly Goods I pledge
this is called Oneness right it's called
Unity
so all guilt is set aside she got you
with a package you got her with a
package
you got all the crap and you got all the
awesomeness it's all in one package
it's there would it be fair enough for
me to is it fair for you to combine all
of your income all of your assets and
all of your liabilities and then begin
to work the baby steps together that's
completely fair you got married dude
[Music]
thank you
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up up
their operations to learn more get a
free product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
if you're new to all this Ramsey stuff
uh go to
ramseysolutions.com click on get started
it's a free service that we have it'll
start teaching you some of the
vernacular some of the words we use
around here like baby steps and debt
snowballs and all that kind of stuff
also it'll kind of teach you where you
are you take a little little assessment
we'll show you right where you are and
then what your natural next steps are
it's completely free we're not trying to
trap you into something we're just
trying to help you so click get started
at
ramsesolutions.com Yolanda's with us in
Atlanta hi Yolanda how are you
good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
well I am calling because
um I have a life estate or my mom has a
life estate and I am the we nanderman is
what it's called I guess when I looked
it up and the remainderman yes yes the
remainderment and I got concerned
because I've heard you talk many times
when people call in about having
property
um
wheeled or whatever to them prior to the
person's death and the and the tax
um ramifications that that involves you
got it
that's what's going on there you're now
the owner of the property
well my mom is still alive no no you're
she has rights to stay in the property
as long as she's alive that's a life
estate
okay
but it's already gated to you
can should I reverse it can I reverse it
how long has it been going on
um I think it occurred in 20
I want to say 2018 I'm not sure I think
it was who did it that
um my mom did it I know me and my mom
with an attorney or yes with an attorney
okay
um I would check your tax Pro
and ask them and check an attorney and
see I don't know since it's been sitting
there so long if you can reverse that or
not if you did it last month you could
just flip the paperwork back over and I
wouldn't think anything about it but
it's been sitting there for three or
four years now
five years now and I don't know honestly
uh and I would make sure I had Georgia
law which is what's going to apply here
because I assume that's where where's
the house
Florida oh Florida law oh and Florida's
got some Wicked weird real estate laws
Florida Texas California in the column
of weird real estate laws and so uh
they're actually weird good most of the
time but not always and because it's an
income tax free state there's no state
income tax there so uh yeah so check out
uh
yeah I think I'd talk to a tax Pro talk
to an attorney and if you can undo it I
think if you run the calculation on it
you're going to see that it's going to
benefit you to undo it because basically
when you sell the house after her death
you're going to be paying capital gains
on everything over what she paid for it
oh no because the house was gifted to
you you got her basis
for tax purposes double check my tax
advice because I'm not always right but
on this one I'm right
okay let me ask you one other question
if you have time
should I go back to the attorney who set
it up would that be best after you've
talked to a tax Pro and you're armed
with knowledge
okay because otherwise he or she may
give you the Arrogant attorney answer
like I'm never wrong because I have a
law degree which of course we all know
is absolute horse crap
agree with you here yeah so I
go ahead yeah in other words you need to
go back to this attorney after you talk
to tax Pro and go look you're going to
cost me with this
an extra forty fifty thousand bucks in
taxes what's the property worth by the
way the property is worth 347 and when
my mom bought the my mom and dad had the
house built
um the house was built for 40K right so
you got a 300K gain give or take upon
her death and um
that is again you would not have to pay
taxes on if she willed it to you now
that it's already in your name you're
probably going to have to pay if I got
my if I got my answer right here as a
remainder I'm almost positive this is
true so 3 15 so 50 000 swing you're
gonna pay you're gonna pay 50 Grand in
taxes because they screwed this up so
yeah I'm gonna go talk to my tax Pro
verify that Dave is not crazy okay which
is possible but um it's possible and
crazy it's also possible I'm wrong but
you know this is going downhill fast
George but well it's it's like going a
whole life salesman going I want to undo
this policy they're going to try to talk
you out of it most likely so that's why
you know you go look because of this my
basis is going to be this
and I'm gonna have to pay taxes of forty
six thousand bucks because you did this
instead she could have just stayed in
her own stinking house and left it to me
in the will and I wouldn't have to pay
these taxes
you get what's called a stepped up basis
upon her death your your basis becomes
what the value of the house is at market
value at the time of the house time of
death so if she dies and the house is
worth 360 you sell it for 360. you have
zero gain you put a hundred percent of
those dollars in your pocket the way it
is now you're gonna pay taxes on
everything over what she paid for it or
about 300 000 gain so it's just it's
just dumb but yeah but um double check
all of that and if it's true then talk
to this attorney about undoing it he or
she doesn't want to undo it I'm talking
to another attorney about undoing it if
I can pull that off five years into this
deal in Georgia I don't know if you can
or not
you might be stuck
I hope I'm not in Florida it's not the
end of the world it's not the end of
Florida I keep saying Georgia but yeah
you're in Georgia yeah I'm in Georgia
yes she's in Florida I'll get my story
straight eventually so a lot of people
do life Estates because they're trying
to avoid probate is that the main reason
yes
or
they just don't know the basics of this
basic tax thing we're talking about here
and it's a very basic it's not a if it's
if it's more than basic about taxes I
don't know it because I don't know
anything about Texas there's about four
or five tax things I know this just
falls into the heading of one of them I
know uh and it's because I've run into
it on different things lots of times
over the years but yeah and it's just
kind of it's like um
I call it Street law
where someone says yeah we're just going
to give Bubba the house while I'm still
alive that way sister won't get it you
know that kind of crap and this is the
that's just Street law and a street law
meaning you think you can just do
whatever the flip you want there's no
tax implications to it yeah you can give
Bubba the house but there's gift tax
implications and or capital gains
implications when you give Bubba the
house or in this case not Bubba but
Yolanda but yeah but I mean it's uh and
less sometimes sometimes people do that
to keep it's not as much an estate
planning thing it's they somehow get in
their head that the government's going
to get more
if they let it happen through a will and
the government gets less if you let it
happen through a will even if it's a
probate even if it's a state where the
probate tax is a little high yeah
probate is still cheaper than that tax
implication yes less than capital gains
tax but there's not I don't think
there's a state that has a higher
probate than capital gains so it's more
about control and
lack of legal and tax knowledge uh
usually than it is some kind of
sophisticated argument that
um that they're there but you can I mean
you can use a life estate if you want to
it's okay especially if you're not
planning on selling the property
like if it's a family farm and you were
going to pass it down 100 it's going to
be generational we're just not going to
be selling it then sure you know that's
fine you go ahead and do a life estate
and
the Next Generation keeps farming it and
the the old people get to stay in The
Farmhouse you know and for life estate
that kind of stuff that's lots of people
do that there's nothing wrong with that
at all uh but but again it's it's in
Yolanda's case it's handcuffed her big
time as to what she can do with this
property someday when God forbid her
mother passes but we're all gonna pass
so was there a right way to do it would
you say if you want to do it do a trust
if you want to avoid probate is there a
better scenario for that I really I
would not make avoiding probate my
primary goal in life
uh because all probate is is the court
system that executes the will
and so if you leave a will the will is
probated meaning that the Probate Court
enforces the will
that's all it means now some tax some
states have higher taxes on the size of
the estate and if you can avoid probate
with a trust or with some of the
mechanisms you're moving it outside of
that probate tax but in an effort to
save a three percent tax on probate hold
up you oftentimes can step over into a
neck deep into the boiling grease you
know I mean it's bad so it's just
completely fried here this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
please
foreign
[Music]
Peace University will teach you not only
how to get out of debt not only how to
live on a budget not only how and how to
agree with your spouse about money not
only how to make it as a single person
with money not only how to invest and
become wealthy but how to be
outrageously generous we've got all of
that in there it's a big deal you're
going to learn how to handle your money
straight up from our experts we've got a
community of thousands of people taking
the class with you and encouraging you
and guess what the personalities the
Ramsay personalities are doing
Financial Peace University classes
George have a bunch of people signed up
for yours oh yeah mine starts June 20th
so I'm later on in the summer uh Jade's
and Rachel starts tonight so that one's
already booked up and ready to go and we
got Ken Coleman Dr John deloney so join
us
Eddie uh Cullen our host is gonna be
leading one as well so pick your poison
and a lot of people are doing it based
off of times and dates so mine's June
20th uh 12 30 Eastern Time 11 30 Central
Time on Tuesdays and Thursdays
at night Rachel's is at lunch I think
yes yeah so anyway you can go to the
page fpu.com just go fpu.com just like
that and or just go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on FPU
you'll find it but the rent the
personalities are doing classes and uh
you can get signed up and they will be
your coordinators now the classes are
still taught by the same videos that
have George and rachel.com it doesn't
change me the content's the same but the
coordinator of the class you're going to
have a energy personality as your
coordinator Tony is in Austin Texas hi
Tony welcome to the Ramsay show
hi David George thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
so I wanted to get your opinion and I
have a little bit of a unique situation
compared to most of your callers I'm 27
years old I've been really fortunate
with the job I have now I've been able
to build up a pretty big messed egg
about 420 000 in cash good for you and
thank you and I just really want to get
both your opinions on how I plan to
diversify it
awesome how'd you do it by the way
I work in medical cells one thing I've
always done really well has been able to
save money but I also have analysis
paralysis and I've been standing in my
own way when it comes to investing
multiplying that money
okay so it's just sitting in a savings
account right now
it is about 100 of it is in a high yield
savings account and the other 320 is
just in a conventional bank which of
course losing the money
and are you wanting to go one particular
way because we generally recommend
mutual funds and real estate as a
general investment recommendation
so and that's part of what I was wanting
to have those feedback on what I plan to
do is I want to keep 50 in a high yield
savings I'm wanting to put 200 into
mutual funds and then the remaining 170
looking to both pay off my reigning
student loan balance and then also put
towards a real estate down payment
so you don't currently have a home
you're renting and how much Consumer
Debt do you have
I only have about 25 in student loans
so the student loans can get paid three
weeks ago
right but before nightfall dude
today
pay off your student loans you hear me
you gonna do that
yep and truthfully I would rather just
pay cash for a home versus get fancy
with investing right now yep yep what
price range home are you thinking about
buying
so of course I don't want to open White
Bridge I ideally want to stay under 400k
okay you've got the money yeah just pay
cash for a home that's your next step
and then save towards uh start saving
towards investing at that point and no I
would not put 50k do you have any an
emergency fund in addition to this or is
this your total cash position
total cash and that's of course not
including the 401K that I keep separate
right right okay
so what is your income
last year was just under 450k good for
you fantastic and you are slaying it
okay here's what I would do if I woke up
in your shoes at 27 years old you've
done very well you're a natural saver
and you have a fabulously large income
so as you said you've been very blessed
but you've also made a lot of good
choices and you're a hard-working guy
and you didn't exactly quiet quit your
way into 450k you've been kicking butt
and taking names way to go I like you a
lot okay so if I woke up in your shoes I
would follow the baby steps because I am
positive after doing this for 30 years
that they are the shortest possible
route between where you are and
substantial wealth the shortest fastest
safest route so first thing is debt free
so write a check today now we got 395
000 left after being paying off the
student loan did I do my math correctly
you did Yep this next step is baby step
three three to six months of household
expenses as an emergency fund we can
call that what we want to call it you
decide what that number is for our
purposes let's see 395 let's call it 45
that leaves us 350 000. if we put 45
into an emergency fund
that is not to be touched for anything
but emergencies by the way that's a
separate savings account not to be
touched for any reason unless a dire
emergency happens and when you're making
450k there's not many dire emergencies
you can't cash flow
okay so this is really really really
really the backstop
so then we move on to baby step four you
start saving 15 of your income into
401ks and Roth IRAs that's going to be a
bit of a challenge but you'll have to
get to doing it making your 450. beyond
that I'm going to pay cash for my home I
think I got if I did my math right 350
000 left to pay cash for a home and I
would buy a home for cash for that much
or less now here's where we're sitting
at this point we have a fully funded
emergency fund we have zero debt
including a paid for house and your
freaking 27 years old
now from there on 450 now you're in a
heartbeat you're gonna have another 300
Grand laying around right
yes sir like a year I mean really how
much can you spend seriously so and
you're not a spender anyway so when the
next time you come to me with this
question with a paid for house and no
student loans and a fully funded
emergency fund George would tell you
okay mutual funds are fine or paid for
Real Estate is fine taking out a
mortgage for real estate investing I
would not do
but I would buy some cash real estate
with this future cash after we've
executed this plan or uh and or I would
do mutual funds
Tony I personally have done both
and I'm the 62 year old version of you
and I now own
millions of dollars of both
real estate and mutual funds tens of
millions of dollars of both real estate
and mutual funds
and so that's where you're headed you're
gonna if you continue somewhat on this
track you're going to have a net worth
in excess of 100 million dollars I
believe it and you don't have to do real
estate sales he's 27 yeah and if you
follow social media they'll tell you you
got to get into real estate if you're
not comfortable with real estate right
now go slow you can just do mutual funds
there's no rule that says but I want you
to have a paid for primary residence
don't buy real estate if you don't
um
enjoyed people and drama
Dave enjoys both clearly I do I mean I I
conflict is like fun for Hillbillies so
I like it you know but it's just drama
and there's going to be some drama so if
you don't want any drama in your life
don't buy real estate because it's even
even commercial real estate you know you
get the small business yeah yeah they
can't go to work because fauci said
there's a quarantine or something you
know I mean stuff like that happens
right so you got all kinds of problems
it's going to be there and with mutual
funds you just open the email and it
tells you how much is in there
no drama doesn't make you as much money
but no drama yeah well there's no either
or both is what we suggest and both will
appreciate over the long term history
has shown us that exactly you can become
a multi-millionaire either way good
mutual funds should be a 10 to a 12 rate
of return the stock market is average
11.2 since Inception real estate all in
with uh value increases cash flow tax
write-offs everything included it's
called an internal rate of return there
should be north of 17 percent if you've
got a decent piece of real estate that's
if you do it right but it's got a hassle
factor that the mutual funds doesn't
have it's got the drama and the people
factor and so some of both or both is
fine anything in there is all right so
that's the plan good question man good
question congratulations what a stud
that's impressive this is the kind those
are the right questions to be asking 27
making 450. I mean
what's he gonna he's gonna be a
millionaire at 20
8 or 29 yeah 28 or 29 ought to be making
that money if he follows our suggestion
if he screws around goes in dead on that
house to buy a house and then messes
around with all this other stuff keeps
the student loan around like it's a ad
you know you're going to have a problem
but don't get rid of it just follow this
system man it's really that's a chump
change in your world it really works why
are you sitting on this student loan
what is it a pet Sallie Mae's an ugly
woman get her out of your house this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you're here George
Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today he's the host of The
George camel YouTube site and oh if you
haven't seen this he is the master of
snark we have a good time I'm a huge fan
I've actually tried to solicit some of
the printers to come up with a snark
font and they haven't done it yet
sarcasm font it would be nice to have
one because some people just don't
understand but anyway yeah you got the
king of snark over here to my right and
he's got a great new YouTube channel
taking on all the toxicity that's out
there and the stupidity that's out there
in the world you don't want to miss this
it's highly popular several hundreds of
thousands of people are already joining
us there thank you for doing that the
George Campbell YouTube channel triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is our number here Christina's in Yuma
Arizona hi Christina how are you
great how are you better than I deserve
what's up
well thank you for taking my question
um I recently sat down with the
educational company that teaches you how
to use a hewock as your primary mortgage
so I know that secondary helocs are a
terrible idea
but they had this idea of using a HELOC
as your primary and only loan at the
house so that like all of your
um deposits and from your job and
everything are put directly in the HELOC
you still have access to it and so the
premise is used since you're putting
everything in it and you still have
access to it you can
that scam is still around I thought that
thing had died this is not an
educational company this is a scam
okay
they're not educational at all
no so their premise is is that you use
the HELOC and you pay all your bills out
of the hay lock HELOC and then you use
your uh uh your income and it's direct
deposited to pay down the HELOC each
month so you're using your HELOC much
like a checking account as if that's
some Advantage Because by the way when
all the money comes in and all the money
goes out the same amounts left in there
whether it's a checking account or a
HELOC there's no magic to a HELOC
okay you follow me
what is your income what's your income
um see combined is around 1 30. okay
thousand okay so let's call let's just
make it up ten thousand dollars a month
okay
right okay so you put ten thousand
dollars a month on your HELOC direct
deposited reduce your HELOC by ten
thousand dollars from your income this
month right then you use your HELOC and
you pay all your bills to the tune of
ten thousand dollars and the HELOC
balance goes back up
you follow me
there's absolutely no change
this is just a checking account
and these guys act like it's mystical
magical and does something different it
doesn't do a dead gum thing it makes
them Rich so it does that
you're paying them a fee for their
education
but yeah you follow me there's no
Advantage at all zero
if you want to pay down your mortgage
all mortgages are calculated on simple
interest
so when you pay down your mortgage it
always reduces the amount of interest
you are paying the next month a hundred
percent of them
okay HELOC or otherwise HELOC simple
interest also so it does not get you out
of debt any faster than a traditional
mortgage by the fact that you're running
your bills in and out of a HELOC and
your income in and out of a HELOC it's
just circular you should the p is still
under the shell does this make sense
okay you follow me
I apologize what was the purpose in
getting the HELOC what made you go I'm
interested in this no because they sold
you suckered into this education company
they're the HELOC she wasn't looking for
a HELOC they were looking for her right
uh yes
um I was looking at uh that's in the ads
about
um how you can pay your house off really
fast and I just was curious and I
haven't done it yet I just let me just
let me let's try let's try again okay
just to make really sure you understand
because I don't I'm not 100 I got
through so the way the house is paid off
is when you pay down the principal
running your bills in and out of the
house your income into the house your
bills back out of the house does not pay
down the principal
if out of your ten thousand you wanted
to reduce principal three thousand you
could just take three thousand out of
your checking account put it on
principle if you put nothing on
principle principal's not going down you
put three thousand on principle that's
the only way the house is paid off
it does not get paid off because you ran
your bills in and out of it
that does nothing to pay off your house
the only thing that pays off your house
is you pay on the principal that's the
only way that's the only way their
system works
but they've got this little uh chart
crap that they show you that you're
going to use so much of your income to
actually reduce principal well duh of
course you can do that anyway and you
don't need them so no run from this
please please run from this how much
mortgage are you talking about taking
out
uh well we just recently bought our
house so we owe around 290. oh okay just
leave that alone then just just leave
these people alone
have I convinced you please yeah okay
right run from Isis averted education
company that's my favorite part of their
marketing scheme yeah I met with this
education company yeah yeah they were
educating you
so um yeah okay so that I thought that
thing man I haven't seen that scam in
probably a decade a lot of this crap's
coming back around though too it's like
fashion Tic Tac is bringing a lot of it
back that's true well the whole life
people's whole another generation that
hasn't been screwed yet so we got to
bring back all the old scams and you
know get to get to the young people well
back in your day that you had to seek
out stupid now it just shows up in your
face at 60 seconds at a time from some
guy yeah your algorithm will help you
get there for sure
um but yeah and the other one was the um
what's the thing called the whole life
savings program a 707 or 770 whatever oh
remember that one no it's the same kind
of crap but it's a whole life agent a
whole whole life I know infinite banking
that's the one that's the one okay
that's the one but it's got It's got a
number to it that they use but it's uh
you know it's also just a complete it's
a scam I don't mean criminally illegal
I just mean it's so stupid it should be
Criminal
that's what I mean by scam it's just oh
like you can Dave debt is tax free you
can borrow from yourself
exactly that whole idea yeah yeah
because 100 of the time you borrow money
borrow money's not taxable people it's
not income
and if you borrow your own money
yeah it's not taxable either and you're
stupid
because you just paid interest to borrow
your own money you're pulling a fast one
on you that's you you got them buddy you
you got the guy oh wait a minute the
guy's me oh crap you just think about
this stuff long enough you should back
yourself off the ledge the problem is
it's all impulsive and a guy told you
hey man and a tick tock I always tell
you that too the other thing the thing
about the infinite Banking and these
guys here too is you will get screwed
More Often by an enthusiastic ignoramus
then you will by an actual con artist
because some of these morons actually
believe this stuff
and they because they believe it they
can make you believe it but it's uh yeah
enthusiastic ignoramuses there's a lot
more of those than actual con artists
they're the same ones selling you a star
in the galaxy Dave with your name on it
those are the same guys they just
switched businesses
it's called an nft Now Dave look into it
you own it I promise
it's virtual ownership I mean just think
about that this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today the question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services after fires or floods
their rainbow restoration Pros offer
homeowners trusted full service
restoration expertise like mold
remediation carpet cleaning odor removal
and more visit neighborly.com today and
you can find rainbow restoration
services in your area today's question
comes from Bethany in Indiana I'm in
baby step two and looking forward to
when I can budget more for my fun money
I'm trying to stay motivated and making
a list of things I can do when I finally
pay off all my debt what are some of the
things you spend fun money on
now that's a fun question a lot of fun
in this question so the things that we
say not to do when you're in debt that
would be first on my list things like
eating out going on vacation uh
upgrading a car for fun instead of uh
because you have to so that would be at
the top is those just things that make
life a little bit sweeter like eating
out so after your hours you could put
back on a restaurant budget put back in
a budget for vacations put back in and
upgrade for um
Whitney and Sharon would say Furnishings
oh that's a nice word we would have to
upgrade the old Furnishings because that
old couch sucks the home decor that was
sticking me in the back with that broken
spring yeah and then there's things you
know your hobbies things that you just
enjoy doing that cost money maybe for
Dave it would be golf these days so
during baby step two we are not devoid
of fun we're devoid of paying for fun
yes ding ding ding ding there's a big
difference see fun is like happiness
like hiking is a hobby that can cost you
nothing so that's a great one there you
go
frisbee in the park but a lot of
people's hobbies are wildly expensive
and they justify so again fun money is
not just for post baby step two but we
limit it while we're in baby step two so
that we can allocate more towards
getting out of debt you know and what's
weird is we often hear stories of people
it makes you reassess
that you can't purchase fun
is a decision or happiness you can't
purchase it it's a decision
you know and so yeah Joy these are
things so I mean for real going for a
walk for real going for a hike for real
doing things the kind of old school
things if you will and think about you
know what what what is entertaining and
it resets your mind because we are so
programmed in our culture today
especially with smartphone right we're
so programmed to think a certain way
that this is where you know there should
be an app that you just went fun and it
just sent you a box you know a box
there's a box of I'm sure there's one
for that I'm sure there is but you know
the the point being that that probably
doesn't have anything to do with your
smartphone
matter of fact I'm pretty sure it
doesn't yeah I mean good relationships
and good Hobbies go a long way more than
you know just going out to the bars
every weekend or whatever it is and look
at what caused you to go into debt and
look at the root of it the things that
were actually pure that weren't to
impress others or things that had the
right motivations and go you know I
really do enjoy XYZ I'm going to
allocate more money towards that and put
a line item in there and then there's no
regret No Remorse once I mean like the
number of times you talk to say an old
person that went through the Great
Depression
not as many left around these days but
if you had the pleasure of having
conversations with them they both they
talked about the Great Depression uh as
both a time of great sacrifice a great
need but they also found a part of
themselves during that time that they
wouldn't have found otherwise and while
you're working to get out of debt you
can kind of discover
you know relationships
Sunshine these important things that are
out there that do qualify for baby step
two stuff it's the stuff Sharon and I
did we did nothing all we did all I did
was work and then if we were going to do
something it was super super super like
no money involved wow you know and and
we got out of debt we got everything
cleaned up and got the IRS out of our
life God help me all right Mitchell is
in Chattanooga hey Mitchell welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so a budget question this year in
January I recently started a new job
that is sales so it's base plus
commission so I have the same base pay
every month but so far in the last three
months the commission's been sporadic so
I'm trying to figure out
how I would work that I use the every
dollar budget and I'm trying to figure
out
how I manage that and work that with
each month being I have the same amount
in base but the commission's different
I'm just trying to figure out how to
manage that Commission
so what would be your worst month
my workouts
just base paid 2500 a month okay and
what are your basic expenses when you
look at your four walls your food
utilities housing Transportation what
does it cost to cover those
maybe 2 000 a month okay including on
your worst month you got all the
Necessities taken care of
correct and so beyond that start to make
the next list of priorities until on the
other end of the spectrum is just the
fun luxuries of life but if you went hey
we don't have money for that this month
we're not going to allocate that in the
budget
okay
and it's a prioritized spending plan for
everything so your three months that
were sporadic what were the three
numbers above your base what were three
commission amounts
uh February was my first month of actual
selling so it was about 2 000 last month
was five thousand and then this month
I'm pulling in uh nine thousand nice
Trend it's been going up yeah so you're
like at 11 5 you're at 11 5 with your
base right
correct you're not earning through the
base it's base plus
correct okay so eleven five for the
month okay you think that trend line
continues
I hope it does but one of the uh what's
the guys that do you what you do what's
the most they make
uh the average among everybody is
between seven and eight
thousand dollars a month
correct yes of commission okay so you're
already above average up to the third
month
correct okay is that sustainable or do
you just get lucky
well it might have been luck this month
I had one big sale come through because
if that fail didn't go through I'd be at
three and a half gotcha okay so what I
would do is I I would budget
your low average of these so I'm
thinking your low average is four or
five k of commission I don't think
you're going to dip below that again do
you
no okay so let's take let's take 5K
that's 7 500 now and let's run a regular
Budget on 7 500 because you're very
unlikely to go below that and then I
mean if you do you step back in correct
your every dollar as you're doing it and
then everything above that do what
George said and say okay if I make a
dime more than 7 500 what is the number
one goal I've got for money
beyond my beyond what I covered with the
7500 right and you that's your number
one okay if I got that done what's the
next thing I would do number two the
next thing I would do number three so if
you're working your debt snowball or
something your number one goal is going
to be that next next dead on the list
right
if you're saving money for uh build up
your emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses maybe step three then
your number one goal would be that throw
money in into the emergency fund until
it's done then once you're doing that
then my number one goal is 15 of my
income oh now we're going to take 15 out
once we get to baby step four oh and
then we're gonna start kids college oh
and then the number one goal after that
I might be saving up for a better car or
I might be saving up for a vacation or
by the way Christmas this year's in
December we ought to get ready and they
don't move it and you know that kind of
stuff so you you start laying these
things out but you're what you're doing
is you're prioritizing every dollar for
the coming month beyond the 7 500 stated
every dollar budget and you just have a
to-do list in order of how I want to
spend it so you always spend more money
on paper than you're going to have
coming in I love it and I'm gonna do one
better hang on the line Austin's gonna
pick up I want to gift you one year of
every dollar premium and there's a great
tool called paycheck planning in there
that will also help you with this along
the way where it'll tell you exactly
when and if you would run out of money
and you can reallocate your spending
your bills for that purpose but I love
people call in Dave and they go well I
can't do a budget Dave because I have a
regular income so that's not for me
you need a budget more than anyone
absolutely because you'll you'll fall
into the thing of trying to out earn
your stupidity
I did that straight commission for years
and uh I almost did it
but the stupid was big it was bigger
than the income so there you go that's
how it goes this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsay personality joins
me here on the Ramsey show as my co-host
uh you want to give away some money I I
would love that never using my money to
give away stuff is my favorite thing I
think it's my spiritual gift at this
point to give away your money Dave
and uh everybody's got to have a calling
and it can't happen for me because I
work here I think that's only fair but
for you all listening out there we've
got a chance for you to win some of
Dave's money and the Ramsay cash
giveaway all month long you can enter to
win up to 500 bucks or the 3 000 grand
prize all you got to do is go to
ramsaysolutions.com giveaway and yes
real people actually win the stuff which
is really cool make sure to enter every
single day to increase your chance to
win there's no purchase necessary but
sorry kids you do have to be 18 or older
to win and today just keeps getting
better because the ten dollar sale is
back and you all know I love a good deal
and this is about uh as good of a deal
as you're gonna get on all of the
products that you need to start Building
Wealth a career you love Improvement
almost all of our best-selling books for
ten dollars that's impressive that's
like when we got some new ones on there
this year yeah Dr John delonese is on
there own your past change your future
uh baby steps millionaires is on there
that's Dave's latest book that lays out
stories of real people including
teachers who became millionaire using
the baby steps and I did some math Dave
because I was curious what three
thousand dollars can get you in today's
world so the grand prize is three
thousand dollars no purchase necessary
and what can three thousand dollars get
you well it can get you 85 days of
doggie daycare if you're me which is
pretty impressive
you're kidding yeah is that a lot to you
or little I don't know what is Doggy
Daycare it's where you send your dog to
be taken care of while you're at work
I can't just wait on you to get home
well you want to give it a good life
Dave you know you send your kids to
daycare why not the dog
the Lord what is this world coming to
you tell me okay uh it can get you less
than a tenth of a Bitcoin if you're
interested in that
um
for two for days okay yeah it could get
you get this 300 copies of The Total
Money Maker now I'm in okay imagine that
all right if you win this giveaway and
you turn around and buy 300 copies of
The Total Money Makeover change 300
people's lives with a coaster for their
that's pretty coffee table here's what
else could get you maybe and I mean
maybe two Taylor Swift tickets yeah one
ending on the day I don't know who the
half gone is but you get one and a half
for that yeah goodness gracious and
lastly this is my favorite it can
actually buy you a beater car in 2023
and James our producer did the research
because I know the haters are coming
after us already here's what this can
get you in the Nashville area at 2002
Honda with 117 000 miles on it
for three grand that's a Jesus car is it
yeah you said they're all in one Accord
don't miss it ramseysolutions.com
giveaway I told you three thousand bucks
it's impressive and all you gotta do is
just
come register that's it come hang out
with us ramsaysolutions.com
laronda is with us in Roanoke Virginia
hi laronda welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you very much how can we help
yes uh I'm currently working two jobs to
try to make ends meet however I'm 59
years old and my credit report shows
that I owe 258 000 in student loans is
there any way I can make that go away
good Lord
you're 58
I'm 59 59. and what did you study and
when
well actually I have three degrees and
with parents and and students going to
college that they make the parents do
the parent Plus loans and pay for them
hold on you said they make them
uh my son wasn't able to get the tuition
for his classes and I had to do Parent
Plus Loans the whole four years for him
yeah or not go to that school yeah okay
so you did yeah yeah so what is your
household income
uh my regular job is like 60 000 a year
I have a mortgage and you got three
degrees in what
uh the first degree was a
multi-disciplinary studies criminal
justice and religion the second was a
master's in accounting and then a master
of divinity in Theology and homiletics
so why does a master's in accounting
only make 60 Grand
sorry about that I don't think that a
master's in accounting area would get
you 60 Grand just so happens the job
that I work at now pays a little bit
more
and you're an accounting full-time
no I'm in logistics I'm a logistics
specialist at Volvo trucks I'm extra
confused so we got the Divinity stuff
you're not doing anything with that we
got accounting you're not doing anything
with that we've moved to Logistics
well you're using accounting and
Logistics but yeah
uh okay and the multi-disciplinary
criminal justice is not in use
um
okay so well the answer to your question
because these are disturbing numbers of
59 years old
the answer to your question is we have
to make more money
and you have not monetized your
knowledge base very well
most people with a master's in
accounting make a hundred hundred and a
quarter a year starting just to get
going you should be able to pass your
CPA with a master's in accounting and
you should move into that field and get
up into the six figures that's going to
be mandatory I'm a little lost as to why
your career is so uh under producing
with all of your knowledge base but
whatever the reason for that you need to
do a little soul searching and we need
to move your income way up like
dramatically a matter of fact I'd like
you to be at 120 heading towards 220.
and by the way supply chain generally
pays more
than 60k
and Roanoke is Roanoke Virginia is not a
backward town I mean that's a
substantial City
um I think that I don't think there's
anything to do with the areas of study
or the area you live in as much as it
does your attitude towards it
well when I when I tried to apply in the
accounting field our handicap is that
through the college that I went to
Liberty University they teach you how to
do everything the hard way but when you
go in for a job interview they want you
to know how to do it through the
computer
where previously we had to do it with
two calculators and work it out the hard
way they want you to already have
experience in sap which is just a
plugging into figures and letting the
software do what it's supposed to do
yeah but that's not rocket science
I know and they think it got sakes I can
do it
right and I can't even operate my phone
hardly so yeah I mean
um
yeah sap is a standard you know you
don't do accounting by calculators and
haven't in decades so
um and
the other piece of this is the student
loans there's no way to just make them
go away I mean you can't even bankrupt
these things and if you want to see
stories of that go watch borrowed future
and so there's going to be a
conversation with the kids I don't know
if they're willing to chip in for their
loans even though it's legally on you
I would still see and say hey mama wants
to retire one day and if they make good
money in their careers can they pay some
of this down yeah
um
you you're gonna if you do not uh get
above this instead of laying under it
in terms of this being your career where
the career problems are all happening to
you and instead you start happening to
the career issues and get on top of this
and get up leave the cave kill something
and drag it home the math on this is
really really not going to go well
60 to pay off
258 at 59 that's the called a small
shovel and a very large hole we have to
change your shovel to whole ratio
mathematically to get you out because
they don't these are not going away
they're not going away
so the way you get rid of them is you
increase your income dramatically and
you keep your lifestyle down at nothing
which it probably already is and then
you just start throwing the difference
at this very very very aggressively so
let's just pretend that over a year or
two of working on this that you got to
let's just be real generous 160 well
that's a hundred above what you're
making now and then you start throwing
100 at 258 you're done in three or four
years because by then it will have grown
some so it's not going to be a straight
line issue so
that's what you're dealing with supply
chain is not a bad field accounting is
not a bad field both are hiring now and
both are computer driven uh and you're
going to learn to operate a computer if
you don't know how if you're going to
win at this so figure out what you've
got to do to get to where your
happening to your career with this
knowledge base because you've paid a lot
of money for all this knowledge and
you're not getting anything for it
and you need to you need to monetize the
knowledge base that's what it amounts to
so hang on we'll send you a copy of Ken
Coleman's book from paycheck to purpose
I'm also going to sign you up free for
his assessment his career assessment I
want you to take that and let's get
above this thing
[Music]
thank you
foreign
personality is my co-host today
you can see his new YouTube channel
anytime you want just check out the
George Campbell YouTube show it's Pretty
stinking incredible hey if you're liking
this show and a bunch of your new thank
you for that just let y'all know the
Inside Story we don't have a 300 million
dollar a year marketing budget we don't
have a football stadium named after us
like oh I don't know or something like
that excuse me allergies are bad last
year because he died the uh uh but
anyway so the only way this show grows
and we help people more people is you
tell people about it
so we appreciate that share it tell
people you listen tell people where your
talk radio show is or talk radio station
you listen to or you can share it
digitally if you're a podcaster or a
podcast listener or a YouTube follower
or something like that you can just hit
the share button hit the Subscribe
button the follow button and that way
it'll automatically show up on your
devices and we'll be there for you all
the time and uh also by the way leave a
five-star review where you can uh one
stars are not helpful mama said if you
have anything nice to say don't say
anything at all but all the five stars
we can get and all the shares and the
follows and the subscribes all of those
things push the show to the front of all
the internet algorithms and cause it to
show up on new peoples
uh searches faster and easier and we get
more and more people we can help thank
you for that we appreciate you Daniel's
in Atlanta hi Daniel welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey thanks Dave thanks for having me on
sure what's up
um so basically
um I have the ability to totally pay off
my home right now but
I am getting married in July and
my uh my fiance she's in medical school
and
by the time her student loans are due
she's going to have around 300 000 in
student loans to pay off and
I was just trying to get some advice on
how I could potentially or what I should
do with with my house right now because
I have
that three-year buffer until any
payments are due
um to help my fiance
so she's got three years of school left
yes and how she pays for that
I'll just
so I'll be helping her she's she's just
taking straight loans
um I'm saying after you're married
uh what is your income
okay
um so right now I I have a fairly
volatile income but my salary is is 110
and uh how much do you have in savings
um I have 275 000 in savings right now
okay what's it take for her to finish
school after July
uh how much yes
the the grand total for her to to finish
up is going to be 300 000.
the total of our whole schooling but
she's already started hasn't she
yes okay how much does it take from this
point forward to finish
um
so she's already so so it'll be that's
going to be the entire total so I'm not
I'm not exactly sure what she's taken
out so far that'd be good information to
get
since you're marrying her yeah what's
left on your mortgage
so I have um well I know that
that it's going to be 300 000 whenever
whenever it's all said and done but it's
not all said and done yet
okay so she's already been in school
what a year
she's been she's been in school
um she's finishing her second year
okay and she's got three more to go
yeah yeah if we call 300 into five
that'd be 60 000 a year if we're
guessing right
no so it's it's gonna be 300 total okay
but my point is here's what I'm trying
to lead towards and you don't have the
numbers and you're trying to box me into
some kind of corner or you just truly
don't know so the deal is this what I
want you guys to do is I want you to pay
cash from this point forward with your
money after from July forward after
you're married I don't want her to take
out any more loans
I want to use your 275 for her to finish
school no more loans and my guess is she
probably has
between 50 and 100 right now
that's my guess okay and so she probably
needs another 200 or so to get through
school but let's budget and set aside of
your cash what it takes for her to
finish med school
that's most important
because the first step to getting out of
debt is not going further in
right okay do no more harm
similar to her Hippocratic Oath she'll
take later right do no more harm all
right okay so we're gonna just we're
gonna cash flow now whatever cash you
have above what it takes for her to
finish from today forward then we're
going to start talking about paying off
her student loans
then once those are gone we're going to
work towards paying off your house
that's working the baby steps first
borrow no more second begin to address
the existing debts that are there
third we have an emergency fund fourth
we build and we start to pay off the
house and maybe step six
that's what you've got it but what
you've got to ascertain to do that is
you've got to find out what it takes in
cash from July forward for her to finish
school and that is a number less than
300 because 300 is all in correct
right okay
we got there so yeah the goal is not to
take any new loans when July hits and
you guys are married so cash flow the
wedding cash flow the honeymoon let's
come back let's look at the pile of
money we have our incomes our debt load
and begin to pay it all off yeah and
then when she graduates and is an MD
hopefully her income will be north of
200 pretty quick and your income so
you're gonna have a three four hundred
thousand dollar household income and
you'll finish paying off the house very
quickly at that point
um with what's going on so you've done a
great job saving money uh you're signing
up for a debt ride that's part of what
goes with July you've got a big old debt
ride but we're not going to just keep
piling on the debt while we reduce the
debt over on the other side on the house
that doesn't make sense at all in a
sense that's like borrowing
student loans to pay off your house
mathematically it's about the same thing
it's just a balanced Suite balance take
out 300. yeah yeah exactly we're going
to pay off 300 on the house but we're
going to take out 300 over here on
student loans so that's the same as
borrowing on student loans pay off your
house which we wouldn't tell you to do
that and nobody would do that on purpose
either it's just a but that's the net
result of all this trying to hide the P
under a shell thing
when people talk about Dave we took a
call earlier and someone said is it fair
because it's not it's not her fault I
went into this debt and we just walked
him through this and went hey you you
saved up hundreds of thousands of
dollars and all of a sudden you get
married and you go oh but I worked so
hard for that I got to pay off her
medical debt how do you overcome that
you are marrying a doctor
so there's hope there's another side
there who's gonna play uh Tit for Tat
quid pro quo here you should be able to
get a great income out of this show as
you go along so I mean there's an
attitude and mindset that goes along
with getting married that's hard for
people to stomach in this very
Independence driven world I worked hard
for this Dave I shouldn't have to pay
off their loans
there is that mentality you know but he
wasn't saying that he was just trying to
figure out the best strategy I was
impressed by him because he was so quick
to go all right I'm gonna pay off her
debt I'm going to cash flow her med
school which is very honor or do I pay
off my house which is wise that's what
he was asking so it wasn't it wasn't a
tight hold on it but that's a that
that's how we'd handle it Daniel
um the other thing that uh
I want everybody to be careful of and
we've seen it in the last hour
um be careful of your language Jesus
said out of the abundance of the heart
your mouth speaks
so I was forced to I'm trapped I'm I
can't do this in our area you can't do
this and all of these absolutism type
statements and verbiages indicate a
victim mentality indicate you're stuck
and you're not stuck
um and and when Daniel kept saying all
in all in all in it's like it
presupposes that debt is the only way to
do this and it's not presupposed because
you called the place where we don't do
it we presuppose quite the opposite
and uh so don't presuppose all in we're
not doing all in we're not going that
that's not the plan we're on anymore it
just changed she's marrying you and you
got money there you go this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people
build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships George Campbell
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
we're so glad you're with us thank you
for joining us triple eight eight two
five five two two five Justin is
starting off this hour in Salt Lake City
hi Justin what's up
hi how's it going Dave great man how can
we help
I'm trying to be able to afford a house
and I've got a business running that's
going about six figures this year
but I seem to be able to barely afford
paying taxes and I'm using credit to do
that
so you're just now starting to make six
figures
yeah this year will be the first year I
will cross over that are you working
with a tax Pro are you just ignoring the
the tax bills when they come what what's
happened here that you've used credit to
pay for it
well estimated tax payments are every
three months and
when I owe taxes I get a little nervous
about it so I just pay what I can with
my credit limit
are you self-employed
yeah I'm self-employed and I got a
part-time job just to cover personal
expenses
other stuff I guess like food yeah so
you're making
taxable income of a hundred thousand
dollars a year
yeah
okay
all right well I mean your quarterly
estimates should be no more than a
fourth of your net profit on your
business how much of the hundred
thousand is net profit on your business
about 50 000 of it
that's half and then the other half is
your part-time job
well the part-time job is only about a
fourth of
where's the other fourth coming from
well so I've got uh about a hundred
thousand coming from the business and
then only about 30 000 coming from my
part-time job
okay net profit on the business is 100
grand
now a net profit would be about fifty
thousand so that adds up to 80 though it
would be your income you said 30 from
the part-time job 50 from the business
so where's the other 20 coming from
you don't have a hundred thousand dollar
income you have an 80 000 income
so it's a over 100 gross not net okay no
gross revenues not profit taxable
household income is 80. you make a fifty
thousand dollar profit on your business
and 30 on your side job am I missing
something
no that's correct okay so the fifty
thousand when you make that money each
month you should be setting aside a
fourth of that so
it's about uh four thousand bucks a
month so you should be setting aside a
thousand dollars a month for taxes out
of your business so you don't get behind
on your taxes every time you make money
in the business you should set aside a
fourth of it pretend like it doesn't
exist and set aside because then when
you get ready to pay your quarterly
estimates you'll have the money to pay
it you're not budgeting in your business
for taxes and then when the taxes come
due you're borrowing them
am I have I got that right
yeah that's right yeah okay you got to
stop that it's not working for you
yeah I try to put away at least 10 no
it's 25.
10 is not covering it that's why you're
coming up short
yeah because you got both sides of FICA
you got 15 3 right there
15.3 your self-employment tax alone
before you get to income tax and then
about another 10 for your income tax on
that
and so you're going to have a 25 a solid
25 in your case
and so it's a it's a thousand bucks a
month if you're making 50 Grand
you got to set that aside because your
quarterlies are going to be three thirty
two hundred somewhere in that range when
you do your quarterly estimates and you
need to have the cash already in the
account because you set the money aside
knowing that bill was coming out of your
profits
you're withholding on yourself
that's the way that works and then that
stops all the borrowing
the reason you're getting in a pinch is
your cash flow system sucks
right right
and there is no try here you saw I try
to put just Auto draft it to savings do
whatever you have to do just never see
that money if you were working somebody
making 50k they would take it out of
your check before they gave you any
money and then you would try to live on
the rest
not I tried to pay my taxes
so you got to do that to yourself is
what I'm saying
because the last thing you want to owe
is the freaking KGB I mean the IRS
they're the last people on the planet
you want to be you get you nervous makes
me nervous too they got unlimited power
and they charge a lot
penalties and interest
and Justin you called asking how to get
a house I think right now we got to put
pause on that while we clean up this
debt get an emergency fund in place cut
up the cards close those accounts then
we can start thinking about a down
payment yeah you got to get you got to
get your debts cleaned up and get your
system right to where you actually know
what you've got to work with to but to
start saving towards buying a house so
how much debt do you have
currently I just got out of debt after
this past tax payment I cleared the
credit just using the business income
good okay so you cleaned up the the
credit all right now when's your next
when's your next quarterly estimate due
it would be after June so I guess June
15th so how much money set aside for
that
currently almost a thousand I'm still
working on beta step number one
no this is not a baby step
but saving for setting money outside out
of your business for taxes is not a baby
step it's before you do anything with
the money
then you have baby steps with money
that's left over so I'd be selling stuff
working that part-time job so you have
four grand by the time those quarterly
estimates are due yeah you do not you
and you just got 45 days not even you
got 30 of them 30 something days
um to get to get to the be ready for
that estimate so that's your main thing
right now just take all your money out
of your business and set it aside for
taxes so you don't get caught up
so yeah Dave this is a new entrepreneur
so what advice would you give to those
who are going Dave I'm self-employed for
the first time I don't really know no
one taught me how to do this the right
way what are the first few things you
tell them to do
open a separate checking account for
your business all of the income for your
business goes into that account only
expenses for that business come out of
that account the difference that's in
that account on cash basis accounting is
profit
you know in other words Revenue minus
expenses equals profit and that's what's
going to show up in that checking
account if you don't do anything except
business things in that account then
whatever's in that account at the end of
the month this new money at the end of
the month it wasn't there last month
okay and we okay put an additional 2 000
in this account net of expenses that's
profit then you need to set aside a
fourth of that and open a little savings
account over the side and set that over
there in his case it's a thousand
dollars a month it needs to be setting a
thousand if he's making 50 profit needs
to be setting aside a thousand dollars a
month over in a separate savings account
not to be used for anything except the
taxes that come up once a quarter and
you have to file quarterly estimates by
your second year in business or you get
penalized for not filing
much less not paying so you don't get
out of it by not filing just like you
don't get out of it by not filing your
taxes
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
good
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today April is in Idaho Falls
Idaho hi April how are you
hi Dave
hey what's up
um so we actually live in beautiful
Salmon Idaho it's a remote vacation
destination my husband and I have been
remotely working for the last two years
we have 1.4 million million in cash
um we owe 360
000 on our house
my question is we're officially debt
free if we pay that house off
um our jobs are kind of going away
so we can move back to a city
get stable jobs I run a business in
Boise Idaho
and that business kind of needs my help
or else it's gonna it's gonna I'm gonna
have to run a half of the year into the
full year my husband can get his really
good job back
or we could buy a second home somewhere
else and kind of do the snowbird
lifestyle my question is this we have
seven children ages 19 to six and we did
Skip baby step number five so how
important is it that we keep our income
higher be more stable support them
through college or do we kind of go for
the dreamy the dreams I guess and trying
to work on careers that we love and
places we love to live
and the kids fit in front themselves
kind of
just turn them loose
well
I mean I don't know part of our idea is
going to Florida half a year working
there my husband's a nurse he can travel
nurse I can start another side gig
or do you mind half the year when we
live in Idaho they can go to school
there we can support them
I guess with housing
but not as much with money
what's your current house worth with the
mortgage on it
um seven hundred thousand
okay and you owe about half of that you
could pay it off today
um but you're thinking about selling
this and moving for work
no we would like we would pay this my
number one
option is to pay this house off enhance
it so it's more rentable because we can
add things to it because this
destination in the wilderness and so we
can add some more rental options to it
make money off of it while we're not
here and then we could buy a second home
for cash in like Florida or Arizona
somewhere warm my husband can make
pretty good money in nursing travel
nursing and then I would probably get a
seasonal side gig in the winter and then
in the Summers I would run my business
in Boise
half of the year
but it's kind of messy that way that's
kind of what I want to ask is that
sounds like that sounds like empty
nesters that doesn't sound like seven
kids yeah yeah I know we would probably
net 200 000 a year if we did the
snowbird kind of Lifestyle with our kids
and we would probably net 400 000 if we
went back to the city
and kept being stable
could you do the 400 000 option until we
get College taken care of and kind of
get our financial situation in order how
old is the youngest
six
no
you need like a 10-year plan we're going
to graduate four kids in five years
um
I don't think there's a wrong answer
unless it unless you call me up later
and say the children were forced to get
student loans because they're not forced
to do that
no
they're not and they I mean our oldest
kids did a lot of dual credit
um so they have two years done of school
our younger kids are already working on
Dual credits our youngest probably will
go first dollars can you cash flow their
school with their help
and can they with your help cash flow
their school if you do your Snowbird
option
I just make less that way the other way
would be I know you make less I said can
they get through college without debt
if you do the snowboard option snow bird
option
I think so I do I don't want to just
dream this I want to lay it out on paper
kid kid number One's Gonna need X kid
number two is gonna need y kid number
three is going to need Z kid number four
is going to need a kid number five is
going to need B and we lay out the money
we look at it and the kid's gonna do
this they're going to get the credits
they're gonna go they're going to work
they're going to go to this school it's
going to cost well it's going to cost a
certain amount of money and here's how
much we have and we're going to tear
into this million dollars in order to do
this uh with their in order to
supplement what they can't cover so they
don't have student loans and what you
can't cash flow because you did the
snowbird option if you can pull all that
off I'm fine with it
and you're going to haul them back and
forth from Florida to Boise right
all right okay as long as you won't do
all that I'm good with it
but it kind of sounds like your Snowbird
thing is like as if you didn't have
children or something
I know I mean because because when I
said Harlem back and forth you went in
did you hear yourself yeah I mean the
ones that live with us would have to go
back and forth the ones that are
launching which two of them are you know
they can decide then we only got five to
haul
yeah how old are you two
46 and 47.
I'll give you a medium plan halfway
between okay
probably doesn't work though that might
work I mean you could go do the 400 for
three years
and that would launch the vast majority
of the kiddos and then the snowbird
wouldn't involve hauling as many
children on its back
right
that's what I was thinking maybe we just
seen a little more time that'd be
unstable yeah I mean you can do either
one uh but part of the downside for me
on your plan is hauling a whole
truckload of kids back and forth twice a
year because you're upsetting teenagers
social networks and family and
everything else you're resetting I mean
Sharon and I it's just us we can run
back and forth and stay wherever and I
mean we don't nobody
cares particularly except grandkids
griping about me me not being around but
other than that I mean there's no we're
not hauling people around it's just me
and her we can go with a backpack and go
but you guys you got a lot of stuff
you're moving around a lot of human
beings you're moving around there so
it's just however you want to do it but
mathematically be sure whatever plan
you're going to do that you map it all
the way out begin with the end in mind
as Stephen Covey said
and that's where I was thinking if she
could use the 400 000 income and quickly
you know front load a bunch of 529s for
the young kids cash flow the older ones
that can get them in a good spot yeah do
that for two or three years not forever
not necessarily until the six-year-old
leaves and the snowbird plan becomes
maybe a five seven years well not even a
maybe a three or four I mean you could
do it for three or four they've already
got a million bucks clear plus a house
clear
so you know approaching a two million
dollar net worth already so well done by
the way on that April awesome well done
so I I just want you to be really
intentional and thoughtful and just map
this out the whole thing out like it was
a business plan
and and you're you know you're
estimating your cash needs and your cash
sources and my Cash Source is my income
my needs are tuition and travel and
whatever else we're doing here and do we
do that on 200 and deplete the million
or do we do that on 400 for three years
and then we'd never touch the million
probably you know something like that
somewhere in there is your answer but
just run it run out accountants would
call it a sources and uses okay what's
your income sources and what are your
uses and map that out through the last
kid getting through college and then
let's figure out which way we're going
to go and that'll give you an answer
that feels it that feels peaceful
uh but just kind of going well I think I
might well no that doesn't work in the
next family movie night everyone watch
borrowed future as a family because that
will spark the conversations about how
we're going to go to college debt free
uh and that'll get a moving but I don't
like the option of they all just figure
it out and get go get student loans yeah
we can do better than that turning loose
seven kids feral is not a good plan this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thanks for joining us America we're glad
you're here open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five if
you've never been to one of our smart
conferences well
that's not smart you need to go you be
smarter if you go that's why we call
them that we'd love to have you hey our
next one's going to be in Chicago the
first time ever we've done a smart
conference in Chicago smart conference
weekend is going to be September 15 and
16 will be Friday night all day Saturday
I'll be there with all of the Ramsay
personalities and we will be teaching
you life hacks about money
relationships boundaries and of course
with Ken Coleman we'll be talking about
working careers so a little bit of
everything will be covered all day
Saturday and then that Friday evening
the early bird prices for General
Admissions only 79 we do have an
exclusive dinner with me and the other
personalities only a handful of people
can come to this and that's the Platinum
Plus ticket we also have platinum and
gold tickets we've got you know up front
we've got book signings we got all kinds
of stuff built into this that you can do
79 your minimum entry and that'll get
you in the door and that's definitely
worth said oh my gosh you'd pay 279 to
hear any one of these speakers and
best-selling authors at another location
so make sure you're planning to come
again Chicago great weekend to make it
September 15 and 16 and tickets are on
sale right now at ramseysolutions.com
events Amanda's next in Salt Lake City
hi Amanda welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you so much for having me sure
what's up
um yeah so about five years ago we
bought our first house and we based the
location
um based on where we were working at the
time obviously things have changed in
the past few years
um I started a job last year that I
really love and it was remote and my
husband still works remotely but a
couple months ago they required us to
start coming back into the office
um I love the job it has helped us in a
lot of ways financially as well not just
because of the pay but they have a
subsidized daycare for the kids of
employees so we bring our kids there
they serve breakfast and lunch at the
office and at daycare so we're saving on
our food bill every month but my commute
is about two hours round trip depending
on traffic
yeah so um and that's what the kids
because the daycare is right across the
street from the office
um so what we're wondering is should we
sell our house right now and try to move
closer I do want to be at this job long
term or should we move out and rent the
house and just rent closer to the office
or just trying to figure out you said
your husband's remote
yeah he's remote he's looking for
another job right now and he might come
to work where I work because he sees how
much I love it but might work remotely
not sure but currently remote yeah well
you I don't know that I would keep yours
as a rental and go rent for a while
because you plan on being there long
term right
yeah so I think it's just time to move
yeah just sell your house
you love you like the community that the
workplace is in
um yeah it's in a nice area
um can you afford it yeah does the
housing market much different
um not a ton different we just hear um
in where we are house prices have gone
up a lot which is good and bad good
because we have some equity and so if we
sold we'd have a nice chunk of change
for a down payment
um but it also is bad because things are
a lot more expensive than when we bought
five years ago that's okay what would
your house sell for today
about 444 okay go buy a house for 450 in
The Other Place sell your house
okay even swap
and you're just down the street no
two-hour commutes
anything wrong with that plan
um
I guess just we kind of
don't want to go through the hassle of
moving nobody does I don't want to go
through the house while driving two
hours yeah I mean after about two days
I'm moving
yeah I don't know how you're doing it
hard to find
I know well I listened to your show even
though my toddler says I don't want to
um well I appreciate that you get two
hours of us but I still would move
yeah it's like tomorrow the tomorrow the
tricky thing is things that are 450
um your house is 450. the officer and
you told us the house prices were
similar your house sells for 450. go buy
another 450. don't use this as an excuse
to screw up your life and boss 8.50 you
can't afford 8.50 go buy 450. you live
in 450 now same house prices
okay
you can do this
you can do this and yeah and just it's
going to cost you a little bit to move
but you're going to get a quality of
life four freaking hours a day
I mean what's that worth a lot yeah and
go jump onto ramseysolutions.com get
connected with one of our real estate
elps endorsed local providers who can
help you with this and also check out
our friends at PODS moving in storage
for this move to make it smoother yeah
both those things will really help make
the process easier for sure take the
headache out yeah but I'm I mean if you
come up ten thousand dollars short when
you're done with this whole thing so
would he you know you're just debt free
you're making the move you got a great
job you'd like the place your husband
likes a place you like the community
make the move make the move and if you
don't want to buy right now sell yours
and go rent over there until you're
ready to buy over there but don't rent
for five years and the house prices are
going to come down no they're not
they're going up
so remember five years ago when your
house yeah I remember okay Brandon is in
Atlanta Georgia hey Brandon welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey Dave I appreciate you taking my call
um so uh get to the point my wife and I
are
um saving for a house we have about 33
000 saves currently
um however our family is growing uh we
have two kids a dog and we have a kid on
the way as well during November
um and we want to well we think uh we
need to get a new car to accommodate um
our family and was just wondering you
mean
correct a different car well so what do
you got now what kind of cars you got
now
so I have a 2000 Honda it needs a lot of
work I'm honestly not really driving it
I have a drive a work truck to work
um and my wife drives a 2013 Sentra and
we just feel like we need something
bigger what will the central sell for
uh my guess is maybe five or six
thousand yeah sounds right what would
the Honda sell for
oh man maybe a thousand no about three
about three I mean because it needs a
transmission oh well not in that case
okay all right I'm going I'm going with
your thousand then okay so we got six or
seven thousand dollars worth of cars
that we're gonna sell and we're gonna
take seven thousand dollars do you have
any money oh you got 33 000 for a down
payment on a house yeah we have we have
a twelve thousand dollar emergency fund
we have 33 on the house so we were
thinking maybe taking some of that house
fun and reallocating it and just wanted
to hear your perspective on if you think
that's an okay idea or what's your
household income
uh together this year we'll probably do
about 140 gross and what are you
thinking about spending on a car
you got seven from Cars
yeah I mean from what we've been looking
at I don't know if we it's kind of
overshooting we we feel like we need a
third row and you know so we've been
looking at it
they each need a row
three kids and a you know and if we have
a dog as well the dog goes everywhere in
the car
not everywhere well good God don't buy a
dog you don't buy a car for a dog dude
okay okay so what'd you do what you come
up to 30 grand now in the car
well no 20 20 or less yeah yeah way less
hey every dollar you spend on this
stupid car is going down in value
through the toilet
every dollar you spend on this house is
going to go up in value right and better
for your family long term so I'm going
to minimize this car I'm gonna take
seven thousand put a little bit with it
let's call it Max of
15. that still leaves you 25 for a down
payment on your house don't screw up
your house deal by buying a car for the
dog it's gonna slow down the savings
goal and so that's the part that's going
to hurt if you drop a whole lot of money
on this car
right there's a balance okay these dogs
are getting expensive listen we've
thought about it Dave the third row for
the dogs if you buy it if you buy it
I'll kill you George you're already pet
ramping listen we return the pet ramp
Dave the stock is over yeah
we taught our dog how to jump one fewer
things to uh make fun of George on this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
our scripture of the Day psalm 16 11 you
make known to me the path of life in
your presence there is fullness of joy
at your right hand are Pleasures
forevermore
Andy Andrews says life itself is a
privilege but to live life to the
fullest that is a choice
George Campbell Ramsey Personality
YouTube star of The George camel YouTube
show is my co-host today John is with us
John is in New York City hi John welcome
to the Ramsay show
George and Dave what a pleasure to speak
to you both you too sir what's up
thank you so I have a question and then
I'll give you the rundown behind it um
so
um I'm currently employed I'm happy at
my job I'm getting opportunities to make
pretty nice Tucker change more
um in other jobs that's pretty much a
similar similar position
um so I'm currently 28 years old I have
about 40 000 in savings
um on debt free thanks to following all
your principles for many years I rent
and
um 90k base salary right now and I have
a good margin
um after you know each month and I'm
just you know I'm so I'm living
comfortable
per se a little High Cost of Living
living area
um so I'm just wondering I'm getting all
these opportunities to go to jobs that I
can make about maybe Thirty forty
thousand dollars more and I just don't
know what to do because I I have a you
know pretty nice culture where I'm at
now but it's very tempting you know
so I'm looking for your what are these
other jobs do you think you'd be
miserable in them are the people toxic I
mean is it worth the 30k jump or is it
hey these are good people too good
company
yeah it seems like it's going to be a uh
an okay jump if I were to I I stayed at
one company for three years
um and then this one for two years so I
don't necessarily like being a job
Hopper the point is are you drop are you
jumping into a toxic mess
um doesn't seem like it I've been in the
industry for five years and I know a lot
of the manufacturers I'm a pretty much a
Salesman for uh uh building materials
um so that's a similar role
yeah similar role
and it's where you want to go long term
in your career
yeah yeah I'm very comfortable in this
career uh made tons of relationships and
it's uh I mean the premise of your
question is is that the culture is not
as good at the other place if the
culture is as good as your place and
it's thirty thousand dollars more why
would you not do that
I don't know it's just uh you know
keeping here keeping um you know I put
so much effort into my current position
I built a lot of relationships uh over
the past two years and uh you know took
a while to to build a lot of trust with
um customers and everything
um so you're gonna start over
um I won't have the same customer base
uh but you know it's the same title and
everything so going you know calling on
a similar industry
um professionals but not so write an
existing customer base or go get a new
one for 30k more
and that's assuming that the environment
the culture is as good is this the
proposal
yeah yeah and that's yeah assuming
there so the only strain is you starting
uh and having to do some scratching and
clawing
yes
I want to mention as well
a mind
what do you think about
should I mention it to my employers now
and I don't know if I can receive a
counter offer in any way or is there a
way to approach that situation
well I I think we need to go back first
are you going to leave
okay okay because if you're gonna go
over to toxic
to a toxic company and you have to
scratching claw no I wouldn't do that
for 30k
you don't want to go do that but if you
can find a company where the
relationships the quality of humans
the value system is as appealing as
where you are and you can make 30k and
the only thing you got to do is do a
little bit of heavy lifting for the
first two years no whining go do it
yeah okay and so now if that's the case
then let's go to your other question and
the best way to think about how to do
business ethics
or conversations with leaders is switch
roles in your mind
let's say you owned a building materials
company and you had a great sales guy on
your team that you really liked
and another place offered him 30k more
what would you want him to do
yeah
me personally yeah I would I would say
maybe let's find a happy medium here
well I would I would first I would love
the opportunity if you're the employer
to know it
and say hey these guys came in you know
they call me they're they're offering
30k more and I'm not in here trying to
hold you up or anything I'm not trying
to Blackmail you I just wanted to give
you this information because I like
being here
um how do you think we can work through
this if you told a leader that they're
not going to be angry they're going to
go uh we can't pay you that you should
go
or they're going to go well crud yeah I
mean we I don't know if we can get you
to 30 today but we can probably get you
20 and get you another 10 if you did
these three things or something like
that right
right but if they don't if they value
keeping you they would value the
information that you might be leaving
I like that yeah absolutely and so it's
just but the big thing is don't go in
this is not a Swagger this is just
gentle
this is not cocky
this is like hey
these other guys and I like it here and
I like you and I like you know I like my
customer base I like what I'm doing uh
but 30k I mean what would you tell me to
do if you were my friend you know ask
the leader of that right and go yeah I
just thought you'd want this information
and let I don't know let's talk about
what how do we work through this
together because I like being here
and instead of like you got to give me
30 or better or gotta match it or I'm
out the door I would tell you to hit the
door
here you'd you'd fire if that was you
you'd fire somebody for that I would too
I'm not going to be blackmailed but I
love information on people I love and
that they've got opportunity and if I
can't match it as the employer that I
you know I care about my people then
I'll just say we don't we can't pay that
here it doesn't make sense to us so man
I'm sorry but I hate to lose you but
good luck with that I hope it works out
for you and I'll just set you free you
know
right right that's why you know you know
then I would be prepared to you know
leave so that's why yeah you got to have
in your mind that's why I solved the
problem first yeah you got to be
emotionally ready for them to go sorry
we can't I think all right yes I'm out
yeah that's so I think your leader is
probably going to step up and get you
somewhere heading in that direction if
you have this conversation gently and
humbly I think that's going to happen
Sarah's in San Francisco hi Sarah how
are you
hi Dave good how are you doing better
than I deserve we're a little short on
the clock can you go fast
I will um one of my dreams is to buy a
house large enough that would take in my
parents
it's been again one of my dreams and
it's an honor to take them back in and
just trying to decide if this is the
right time for me to make that move and
buy that larger home are you renting
right now
I have a home right now
how old are they
um my parents are 72 and 82. okay
and what does this involve yourself
you're selling the house you're in which
sells for what
so right now my house would sell for
about 1.7 million and I owe about 600
000 on it okay and you would move up to
what
move up to 2.5 million
so 800 000 increase
okay that's pretty generous
yeah you you could pay a lot of rent for
them and an apartment for 800 Grand
yeah I don't think
um I need to be close by to just for
caretaking reasons as well yeah okay so
where's the 800 Grand going to come from
so I have liquid of a million right now
um all right do it
do it okay it's what you want to do with
your money
you're a multi-millionaire you got about
a million of equity plus your million
cash congratulations yeah
thank you pay cash for the move and do
it don't buy a house that is a bad house
uh that's a bad mother-in-law apartment
okay meaning that when you get ready to
sell it after they're gone someday that
your house is weird
don't buy a weird house just buy a big
enough house that they've got a place to
stay and then when they're gone the
house is not a weird house that puts the
Ramsey Show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
so and want to know more about getting
started on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started